what is going on there reject nation
greg here today now before i get into
everything i've been hearing i'm going
to declare this
please subscribe click that notification
bell to get notified when a reaction for
the official trailer is up you know
after not the week but when sony and
marvel officially release it
get notified and also i encourage you
i'm encouraging you to follow me on
social media so you can blow up my inbox
i
i don't want another eternal situation
so once i see my phone it's just blowing
up with notifications i'm going to
immediately assume
that it's for the spider-man no way home
official trailer so here's what i've
been hearing okay i have been hunting
this down barely any sleep right now
because i i just really want to make
sure we're on top of this okay
all right so after the leak yesterday
this is seeming even more likely now i
was listening to campia earlier he was
talking about he's actually going to
cinemacon tonight and then daniel rpk a
source that has been extremely reliable
he's usually right on the money and this
time around he's not declaring it to be
a hundred percent which is kind of rare
because usually he is like he only says
something if he's 100 sure about it but
most likely when it airs at cinemacon
tonight it should go online that is the
main hub like i've been talking to a lot
more other people especially because of
the fact that the early draft the
unfinished version
recorded crappy quality leaked online
yesterday that it just seems extremely
likely that's gonna go up tonight or
tomorrow morning so i am hoping i am
really hoping guys that if this is the
final trailer update then that the next
time you see us talking about spiderman
no way home that we are just doing a
reaction to the official trailer that is
my main hope after tonight or after
tomorrow morning we do have like a
little opening sketch like a three
minute opening sketch we're gonna play
before the reaction that right there i'm
i'm just telling you guys right now that
is for people who regularly follow us
you'll know what i mean when you watch
the video we made it you know it has for
you guys as much for us i know that new
viewers might not give a damn about it i
might just skip it which is fine but for
those who are like you know subscribers
of us and i've been watching our videos
regularly over the past few months
the sketch is for you guys so i'm hoping
you guys really enjoy it and i hope you
leave a comment about it and last thing
i'll say is i know yesterday there were
a lot of people who were asking and like
informing us about the trailer leak we
have not seen it we refuse to watch it
now i know there's been some people most
have been very understanding is sort of
reasoning of why not to watch it but
there have been some who have been a
little critical of it and i'm just going
to make this clear right now some people
have been like why why would you not
watch it when you've already like
covered and reacted to so many like
leaks and stuff over like like cosmic
wonder or you know even like what 3c
films talked about or heavy spoilers or
whatever that's been different because
that comes a lot in the form of
speculation and a lot of the time too
there's been so many reports that a lot
of them have cancelled each other out or
have just been wildly conflicting and
it's not the same as experiencing the
the visual language of what sony and
marvel officially want to release the
last thing i wanted for a trailer we've
been waiting for for so long is to
experience it in that crappy quality
if you want us to have the best trailer
reaction possible to really feel it
it has to be the version that we've been
waiting for so we just don't mind
waiting another day or two for it
hopefully i'm really hoping this is the
final update for it i want to thank you
guys have been with us on this journey i
really do believe it's tonight or
worse tomorrow morning
just won't sleep for the next 24 hours
because i just want to make sure we get
it to asap thank you guys for the
support
hopefully next time you see us talking
about spider-man it's cause we're
watching the official trailer
[Music]